hello and welcome to Ed talks with Khan
Academy where we talk to interesting and
important people in the education space
I'm Kristen deservo the chief learning
officer here at Khan Academy and looking
forward to a conversation today with Dr
Chase nordengren who is a chief a
principal research lead at our partner
nwea before we get started I want to
remind you that Khan Academy is a
non-profit and we are able to keep doing
the work we're doing because of donate
nations from folks like you if you go to
Khan academy.org donate you will find an
opportunity where you can donate and
help us continue to do the work that
we're doing and we're thankful for
anything that you are able to give
we also want to acknowledge some of our
supporters who have helped us going
through the covid-19 crisis including at
T General Motors and fastly
if you want to hear this conversation
again or you want to hear past
conversations or listen to them while
you're working out taking a walk
whatever your preferred podcast
listening practices may be you can find
us homeroom with Sal the podcast
wherever you get your podcasts
and with that let me welcome Dr Chase
norngren welcome Chase
thanks Kristen uh thanks for having me
happy to be here
absolutely let me tell folks a little
bit about you so you are a principal
research lead for Effective
instructional strategies at nwba so tell
us a little bit about what what your job
is what does that entail
sure my background is as an educational
researcher so I went to graduate school
studying all different kinds of
educational research I've been at NWA
for about six years my job is really
focused on working with our professional
learning and our school Improvement
teams to understand what great
instruction looks like so on the the
best days I get to get in the classroom
talk with teachers and principals about
what's working really well how they're
applying not only
our products and services but also you
know other useful pieces of curriculum
and instructional
technology to the work that they do and
try to extract the lessons from that to
put it into our professional learning
our school Improvement to the other
things that we offer
how did you decide to go into education
research as a career
it's a good question and I think I took
a kind of roundabout road so I uh
started my career wanting to work in
politics uh feeling uh really strongly
that I wanted to make a difference in
social policy and construct social
policies that were going to help people
I spent enough time there to realize
what I didn't know and to understand the
kind of central importance of the
classroom and what makes for a positive
educational outcomes for kids and so
convinced myself as a result of that to
make a little bit of a career switch
went to graduate school with that focus
in mind and ended up in a place now
where I feel like I have a really strong
opportunity to interact with and make a
difference in classrooms across the
country
very cool so I know you have written a
book called step into student goal
setting a path to growth motivation and
agency so let's talk a little bit about
goals and goal setting what do effective
goals for students look like
yeah I think one of the reasons I really
wanted to write the book is that I think
goal setting and goals are are a great
example of the kinds of instructional
practices that work really well
um one of the things that's true about
them is they all look kind of different
but follow a set of kind of kind of
common principles common ideas that I
hope through the book we can Elevate and
we can share out with with other folks
um three kind of big principles that are
true of really effective goals first of
all they're individual they're they're
tailored to the individual student
second
um they exemplify what we call a Mastery
orientation they promote learning for
learning's sake and get students excited
about learning for learning sake
um and then finally they balance what is
Meaningful for that student with what is
attainable for them they come with the
support and the guidance of an adult who
can really help help a student pick
something that they can accomplish but
there's also enough of a elite for them
that when they achieve it they'll feel
really accomplished and really proud of
themselves
that totally makes sense so it sounds
like you need to learn how to set good
goals along with learning other things
too so how does a teacher start
implementing this in their classroom how
do they start helping students set goals
I think it's a great call out one of the
things that surprises a lot of people
when they first encounter this work is
that goal setting can really start the
first week of kindergarten and you know
in those early years I think it's not so
much about making sure that we always
accomplish every goal that we set but
that students get accustomed to the
practice get into the get into making
goal setting part of the the culture of
the classroom and so it can start you
know with really simple things with
little week by week or month by month
learning outcomes
um you know the the number number of
letters a student is able to master in
those Elementary grades or those you
know simple math facts but really it's
about giving students an opportunity to
see what they're learning week to week
month to month see how that connects
back to the things that they want to do
and the kinds of people that they want
to be and eventually giving them enough
practice and experience that they can
start to take more and more ownership of
that process so that they can be more
and more responsible for setting their
own goals over time
that makes sense could you give us some
examples of like what a goal would look
like for a kindergarten or first grader
or a middle schooler or a high schooler
sure
um at the Elementary grades one of my
favorite examples from the book is a a
first grader who was really into frogs
um so you know teachers in the audience
have had this experience kids who come
in with a just kind of dedicated Focus
um you know for him the books that were
at his reading level
um in first grade we're not teaching him
anything new so what his teacher did was
she used that as the motivation to say
okay if we work on these three or four
reading skills we're going to build your
reading fluency so that you're able to
access more complex books about frogs I
bring up that example because I think
we so often default to thinking about
goals as related to the colleges and
careers that students want to pursue
when they leave secondary school and
that's that's an important piece but
it's not the only way that students
start to express the things they're
interested in or the things they want to
do
um so I think at you know whatever the
the grade level is about taking those
immediate academic outcomes that you're
pursuing for that week or that month and
knowing what the student is all about
what they're interested in doing and
helping them make the make the
connection between the two
um those will obviously get a little bit
more complicated as you enter into the
Middle grades and have some more complex
academic outcomes you know once you get
into High School ideally students have
had enough experience that they can
begin to think a little bit longer term
and begin to think about how those
skills might factor into their college
or career Readiness but important to
demonstrate that it can happen at any
grade as long as it's you know tailored
to what that student is ready for
got it so I'm the first grader who's
going to learn some new reading skills
to learn more about frogs like is there
a goal that that first grader is going
to write down that they you know
understand and can track
yeah
um I think this is a really important
part of um the process of effective goal
setting across all of the teachers we
worked with is the one-on-one
conversation so the conversation between
the teacher and the student were there
in the first class you know setting that
initial goal uh on an ongoing basis
tracking progress on that goal and
eventually celebrating
um that the student has have achieved
that goal we give a lot of different
examples in the book of worksheets and
tracking documents that teacher can use
to help the student write that down and
track it over time I think the specifics
of those are less important than the
general practice of writing that down of
being asked to make the connection
between the academic goal and something
broader they want to achieve and being
given the opportunity to track and
monitor their success with that that
over time
that that makes sense I know when um I
talk to folks here at Khan Academy about
motivation
I talk a lot about expectancy value
Theory so people do things when they
think they're going to be able to be
successful at them and when they find
some value in doing them and it seems
like goal setting just fits actually in
both of those categories in like hey I
can see I'm starting to have success and
I'm setting goals about things I'm
valued at does that do those does goal
setting fit into motivation theory in
that way
yeah I think that that fits really
nicely with
um that third bullet point that I
mentioned before the idea of balancing
what is attainable with what is
Meaningful
um so certainly that meaning part is
really important and you know asking a
student to complete something that they
can just kind of do by Road
isn't particularly meaningful right
um in the same way that if I asked you
to tie your shoes you're probably not
going to remember or take much from that
experience
um at the same time students need to
have that ongoing evidence that they are
succeeding
um and in the course in the classroom
that often means providing a lot of
those touch points uh sometimes called
formative assessment where students can
actually take an effort to to try out
tasks perform the task and see
themselves getting better over time I
think one sometimes overlooked
ingredient is that making sure that
students have those really frequent
opportunities to see themselves progress
yeah that absolutely makes sense so does
that look like
you know tracking sheets or online tools
do you have some suggestions for how to
track progress
yeah I think all of the above right so
we have a a bevy of online tools uh map
accelerator's certainly one of them that
gives students the opportunity to uh
practice a particular set of skills and
to see themselves improve over time we
also have a variety of analog tools so
whether it's you know the kinds of
project-based activities that are
Incorporated in a lot of classrooms
already or those online tools are a
combination of both
um I think we're we're looking for the
kinds of classrooms where students
individually in small groups as a whole
group get lots of opportunities to
practice with the skills that they're
building and have the ability to see
those practice opportunities as an
opportunity to reflect on what they've
learned
oh reflection that is one of my other
um things that I'm interested in and so
do you think as part of goal setting
there's a how do you think about that
encouraging students to think about
reflection or their questions you can
ask to encourage that that teachers can
can build on yeah
um you know student reflection I think
of as another aspect of that formative
assessment cycle that really Taps into
metacognition I'm helping students think
about their thinking and see their
thinking in real time uh you know I
don't think the questions themselves
have to be that complicated so
um you know a lot of the worksheets that
we include in the book uh include
questions as simple as what's one thing
you learned this week what's one new
skill you've added what are some of the
things that you struggled a little bit
more with than some of the other things
um I think you know finding great
appropriate questions that are tailored
to where kids are but just that start
the train of of thinking about how they
are learning
um can really be a way to to jump start
some of those deeper Reflections
obviously those can come out in
conversation as well and conversation is
another important
um one of mine is
uh did you get stuck and if so how did
you get unstuck
that's a great one have them thinking
about how to how to persist when they
get into difficulty I think is a so
there's a lot of there's a lot of
stylistic elements here too right like
every teacher has a slightly different
style they have a different approach
they have questions they like and don't
like and
um the intent of the book and our
promotion of this practice generally is
absolutely not to try to uh level those
out or make every teacher teach the same
way it's about taking these principles
that are backed by research backed by
the conversations that we've had with
these really high performing goal
setting teachers and thinking about how
to apply those principles to your own
practice how to bake them into what
you're already doing so that first of
all it doesn't feel like a kind of added
task another thing for a teacher to do
but second so that the the goal setting
process can really reflect your teaching
personality reflect your style reflect
what's already working for your students
that makes sense so we're in back to
school season here in Arizona kids have
been back for about three weeks but I
know in a lot of the country they're
just heading back now
um what are your recommendations for
teachers around goal setting kind of as
we move into early stages of the year
yeah I think now is the time to begin
setting that culture
um so obviously you'll have a better
understanding of whether the students
coming into your classroom have had a
lot of experience with this or they have
no experience at all if you're starting
from Ground Zero
um group goals can be a great way to
start
um so thinking about things that the
whole class can do together and
celebrate uh whether those are academic
in nature or even whether they're
they're behavioral
um but giving students the opportunity
to practice engaging in the process is I
think as important or more important at
that early stage than making sure they
can succeed at every goal they set so
for the teachers who are really
successful for this I think a lot of
them spend the first month or two just
getting students accustomed to the
process showing them what it looks like
giving lots of examples from their own
life without times when goals have
succeeded for them and really kind of
laying the groundwork so that by the
time we enter into November December
students can start to think about what
their own goals would look like and what
they would do to get there
great so let's grab a question from
Facebook John Posey asks what are some
techniques for how you encourage
continuation to strive towards a goal so
if a student shows interest for example
in the Frog book how do you get them to
keep keep pushing through that instead
of kind of losing interests
yeah this is I think the reason why
those conversations are are really
important and the the teachers in the
book who are really successful were
having one-on-one conversations with
students every two weeks or even every
week about their goals I can seem really
daunting but it can be very simple very
informal very short just an opportunity
to say to the student hey as an
individual I see you I know this is
where we're working towards what are
some of the roadblocks that you put uh
found this week and what are some of the
ways that we can overcome them I think
having those individual contact points
with students no matter how kind of
short and simple they are is a really
powerful tool when making sure that
they're able to persist and that those
little roadblocks don't turn into really
big ones
yeah that makes sense
so we've got another question which I
think is our most asked question
um that almost every every expert we
have on uh we want to to tap this so
this answer can be about goal setting or
it can be more broadly but um Dio Brando
asks what should I do to motivate myself
to learn more what's a good way to learn
by myself and so we get this kind of
General motivation question from
from students from teachers from parents
what are some of your just go-to
strategies around motivation
well I I think this is absolutely
apropos goal setting because goal
setting is is really about you know as
an individual taking a really big task
so a big thing that I want to learn and
breaking it down into those uh bit by
bit elements that are going to help keep
you focused and and keep you motivated
um I think the most important thing and
and you can do this individually you can
do this with
um someone you're working with is make
really clear why you're doing it make it
really clear what uh interests you in
learning about this particular area of
mathematics this particular area of
History how does it connect to the
things that you want to do and the kind
of person that you want to be whether
that's a career orientation or whether
that's a personal orientation
um you can think about writing that down
in some kind of reflective exercise or a
journal you can think about you know
doing a little bit of research on up
front to understand what are the kinds
of skills that this particular career
requires or
um what are the kinds of ideas that
they're wrestling with in this area
um but I think the most important thing
you can do to keep that motivation is to
make that relationship really clear
um and then set goals that can help you
take the kind of big ambition of you
know I want to learn calculus and break
it down into the little bit by bit
pieces that will show that you're making
progress and understanding more over
time
calculus is a good example because I'm
going to be honest I never really could
saw how calculus it was going to be
relevant to the jobs that I wanted to do
I was thought I was going to be a
psychologist and yes I use statistics
but I don't really use calculus based
statistics but one of the things that I
found as I was taking my required
Calculus class was actually if I could
also just see it as a way to think about
how amazing math is and how it helps
explain things in the world even if it's
not necessarily what I'm going to do in
my career so I also sometimes wonder
because it is the case that sometimes in
school we have to do stuff that isn't
really going to be related to the thing
we're going to do when we grow up and
get a job but if there's also some
thinking about just
how um you know building that just
understanding of how the world works and
how things go that we can build on to
for teachers I don't know if you have
any thoughts on on things that maybe
aren't directly tied to what we're going
to have to I'm going to want to do with
our lives but we kind of have to do
anyway
one of the interesting distinctions that
comes up in the research in the book is
the distinction between individual
interests and situational interests
individual interests are those things
that you care about already you probably
cared about them for a long time they
drive and motivate you situational
interests are those things that you come
to care about in the moment in a
conversation with somebody else
um I think one of the things that we
take for granted is that young kids
especially haven't had a lot of
opportunity to develop those individual
interests yet they just haven't been
around for enough years on the planet
Earth and if you think about a lot of
the individual interests that you have
today whether they're professional or
whether they're personal you can
probably Trace those back to some
conversation that you had with someone
where they made that connection between
that particular topic area and something
that that was going to motivate you and
and challenge you one of the other
examples that has come up as I've talked
about books around this book is about
learning grammar right getting students
interested in the rules of grammar is
it's really difficult because it feels
really abstract and you don't know how
to apply and the idea this teacher had
is starting by talking to students about
being good communicators most people
want to be good communicators they may
want to communicate about different
things but we all have that driver to be
to speak to express ourselves and to be
heard effectively and so just making
really clear as the introduction to the
lesson why learning those rules and
techniques of grammar we're going to
help students become better
communicators for whatever they wanted
to do was a way that this teacher was
able to make that turn that situational
interest into an individual motivating
interest
situational interests I like it I'm
taking that as a as a takeaway from
today excellent thank you I do want to
shift a bit to another topic so coming
from nwea as as folks may know uh NWA
and Khan Academy together have an
offering we call map accelerator where
using your map growth score from nwea we
can then find the good the best
placement in Khan Academy math content
based on what you know and what you are
are just ready to learn and we have just
released a study of some efficacy
results from that so chase you want to
tell us a little bit about that study
yeah so you know as we mentioned before
map accelerator is a great example of
the kind of activity that can result
from a goal setting process right that
you give a student this place where they
can individually practice the math
skills that are at their next level of
development what they're ready to learn
next and gives them an opportunity to
experience that kind of frequent success
over time as they learn more
um so in the study uh the group of
researchers who worked on it worked with
about 99 districts who were using map
accelerator in their practice and they
um were able to see how much time
individual students spent with
accelerator so we recommend that
students spend about 30 minutes a week
or more working with accelerator and
obviously there were schools and
classrooms where students did that there
were schools where they didn't
the study finds that students who spend
at least 30 minutes a week experience
greater than expected growth from from
Fall to spring so what that means means
is compared with the average growth that
students at that grade level experience
over the course of a given year students
who used map accelerator as recommended
experienced anywhere from nine to 43
greater growth than we would have
expected
now and those Trends were fairly
consistent across grade levels across
student demographics Etc now it's
difficult to draw what researchers call
cause a link between those two but it
does suggest to us that participation in
mapped accelerator as intended is
associated with greater growth than than
would be expected if students hadn't had
that engagement or they hadn't used the
product for 30 minutes a week
yeah so I know I've been excited about
this because 30 minutes a week isn't
that much
we can like we can find 30 minutes a
week to to think about this and one
question when we say greater than
expected so the the map growth uses what
we call Norms right and so were those
Norms from before the pandemic time so
we're comparing students before the
pandemic
yeah this isn't a this is an important
caveat so the Norms were created for the
pandemic and and as uh you may have seen
in a lot of the work that we've done
since then uh student growth generally
across the board was uh lower than
expected compared to the Norms over time
so the fact that students who were also
in the pandemic period during the time
the study happened experience greater
than expected growth
suggests to us that the the margin
between students who are using map
accelerator and Suits warrant might be
even larger than what we found
yeah that's really interesting so thanks
for sharing for folks that want to read
more we have some links in the chat to
the those studies where you can dive in
and uh and find out some some more
information and and uh see the see the
results for yourself
so fantastic so before we we close out
uh I have a a couple other uh questions
uh Cameron it looks like we answered
your question I think right before we we
shifted to this
um Shaheed Khan on Facebook says how can
we gain attention of students who may
have uh personal issues that are
influencing and kind of interfering with
their learning process when there's
things going on outside of the classroom
maybe or other things how can we help
them stay on track with learning
uh you know this is um one of the
reasons why that individual relationship
with students is really important so
that you can understand in the course of
that conversation what are the kinds of
barriers this student might face to
accomplishing their goals
um and that's going to look different
for every student and and as a result we
might set different kinds of goals for
every student right there may be some
goals that are more uh what we kind of
call social emotional or behavioral
right the the amount of time uh the uh
whether or not they're able to come to
school on time
um you know whether or not they complete
their homework that sort of thing
um I think all of those barriers whether
they're academic or whether they're
social emotional are are barriers to
learning and so they want to find ways
to address them we want to help
challenge students to help overcome them
at the same time I I think it's super
important
um not to write kids off we're
experiencing those difficulties you know
every student can be challenged from
where they are and while those
challenges might look a little bit
different based on what kinds of
resources students have access to or
what's reasonable to expect them to
achieve making sure that all students
are challenged in one way or another is
part and parcel in making sure that all
students are heard when they enter
school and so I think it's it's
important both to know and to understand
what students are going through and to
find ways given those those challenges
and constraints to push them to what
they're capable of achieving next
yeah thank you uh one more question that
I think is interesting so do Brando says
I'm almost 15. what should I know what
should I be studying by this age
it's a great question and I think the
only real way to respond to that is with
another question so you know uh what do
you want to be and what do you want to
do and that doesn't mean to be as
specific as this is the kind of job I
want to talk for what I want to do for
the rest of my life
um but there are a lot of different ways
to take those things that you want to be
and do and uh convert them back into
goals and then the a has a tool called
the college Explorer tool which lets you
put in some kind of Institute of higher
education whether it's a university or a
trade school and see what kinds of
scores on our map growth assessment you
would need to be getting in order to be
eligible to participate in that school
the Department of Labor has a database
called onet which is really fascinating
it shows you the skills that you need
for just about any kind of career you
can imagine makes that really clear so
that you can understand what are the
kinds of things I should be studying in
school to get there
um but I you know encourage you to to
keep an open mind to think about the
kinds of things that you want to do and
want to be as you get older and to
really look for opportunities that all
of the subjects that we focus on in
school uh connect to
um those things that that you want to
become
me too so if you see some of those
skills on the different sites of the
kinds of things you need to know and you
want to test them out see if those are
interesting to you or see where you are
on those skills you can always also jump
on some of our we have courses in lots
of different areas that you can also
just dip into a little bit and see how
how you like them and see where your
skills are so feel free to explore that
way too but I'd like the ideas of having
some targeted based on what you want to
what you might be interested in and want
to do in your future
fantastic so uh Chase what are to close
out what are some things that um you're
working on right now or that you're
looking forward to in the next year in
terms of what you're doing at NWA
yeah
um so my next uh line of work which I
think is related is really helping to
understand how how teachers tailor their
instruction to meet students where they
are and so we're working closely with a
group of Elementary and Middle School
teachers who have experienced
exceptional growth with their students
and I'm working uh with them directly
through interviews and observations to
understand what does your instruction
actually look like and what are some
bits and pieces some techniques that we
can pull out of this and help to
encourage others to other teachers to
use to think about how they can support
students during
um this this particularly difficult time
when students in the classroom span age
ranges span ability levels span
um grade levels of opportunity how can
we
use these techniques to meet students
where they are
great we'll look forward to hearing more
thanks for joining us today
thanks so much Chris
great and before we leave we've talked
about goal setting today want to remind
folks that uh if you are in a classroom
using Khan Academy you can participate
in our national learnstorm fall
challenge which is about setting
classroom goals for skills that you have
mastered and see together as a class how
many skills you can Master over the
course of this challenge so check that
out and we look forward to seeing you
next time on Ed talks
foreign